Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Old school vlogbrothers video where I sit
down with no idea what I'm going to talk about..
about, what I'm going to talk - whatever,
sometimes you need to end a sentence with
a preposition.
Okay, so a while ago I was getting dressed
for a cocktail party and I was putting on
like, proper fancy pants and everything, and
I was looking at myself in the mirror, and
I said to Sarah, "I feel like I look like
a middle aged man in this outfit".
And then Sarah paused for like a quarter second
too long before saying, "Nonono you look great!"
And I realized, I look like a middle aged
man, because I am a middle aged man.
Like if I die at double my current age, people
won't be like, "Oh, it's a tragedy", they'll
be like, "Nyehh, he had a good run.
Coulda been better, wasn't terrible".
My theory about middle age is that if you
triple your current age, and that's like a
reasonable age for a human being to be, then
you're not yet middle aged.
I mean Hank you're 33, you triple that you're
99, that's right on the edge.
I'm 36, you're triple that, that's 108.
Living to 108 doesn't even seem like a good
outcome to me.
Anyway, there are tons of obviously negative
things about being middle aged, but there
are also some advantages, you know, like the
stability of adulthood, and the pleasure of
parenting.
But the biggest thing, Hank, is that no one
expects me to know anything about pop culture,
which is great because I don't.
And this brings us, belatedly, to Justin Bieber.
To be honest with you, Hank, I know this sounds
crazy, but I don't think I've ever heard a
Justin Bieber song.
Actually, I'm gonna listen to like his top
5 songs right now, and see if I've ever heard
any of them.
Hold on.
Okay, this one's called "Boyfriend".
It has like, 3 hundred million views.
I haven't heard this song before.
It's kinda good.
Is he a rapper?
It's a good song, I never heard it before
though.
Alright, lets see the next one.
Okay, this one's called uh, this one's called
"One Time".
Oh he looks much younger in this video.
I kinda like this one as well.
Although he just rhymed "knock" with "stop".
Yeah, I never heard that song before in my
life.
Okay, let's see what's next.
"Beauty and da Beat", featuring Nicki Minaj.
Nope.
Uh, I have never heard "Beauty and da Beat".
I'm only gonna try one more.
It's the most viewed one ever.
It's called "Baby" and it features Ludacris.
This seems familiar to me.
I feel like I have heard this song before.
I feel like I've heard it, but I feel like
I've heard a cover of it or something?
Anyway, that one is definitely familiar.
"Baby" featuring Ludacris is familiar to me.
So there you have it, I've heard one Justin
Bieber song, I think.
And yet.
Despite my obvious and complete ignorance
of Justin Bieber and his work, I can tell
you that Justin Bieber was recently arrested
for DUI, driving a rented Lamborghini, and
in fact, I can tell you the color of that
Lamborghini: it was yellow.
Why do I know this, Hank?
Non-rhetorical question.
Why do I know about it?
I have no investment in Justin Bieber, I mean
I don't think he should drink and drive, but
I don't think anyone should drink and drive.
Why do I know the color of that Lamborghini?
Why do I have the image of Britney Spears'
shaved head imprinted upon my mind where I
might be remembering, I don't know, how to
speak Dutch or something.
So Hank, I feel like a relatively small number
of people raises someone up to the level of
celebrity, and then everyone gets to participate
in like, relishing their downfall.
It seems to me that Justin Bieber is now more
likely to be on the cover of tabloid magazines
than he was back when he was doing really
well, like in the "Baby" era--
OHHHHHHH!
"Baby"!
It's from your song Hank!
The "Ice Cream Changes" song, I know it because
of your song!
If you don't know what I'm talking about,
link in the Doobly-doo.
But Hank, I haven't heard that Justin Bieber
song, I only heard your cover of it.
I'm still zero for Bieber!
Or, I was, until I listened to those songs
anyway, which I quite liked.
Hank, I don't want to excuse anyone's behaviour,
and I certainly don't want to act like celebrity
is the most troubling form of oppression out
there.
But I do worry about the way we approach celebrities'
problems with relish.
Not so much because it's bad for the celebrities,
but because I think it might be bad for us.
I don't think relentless public chastising
much helps anyone.
If it did, we would see this happen less,
and we aren't.
Hank, it's really hard to choose what we pay
attention to, but I think in a lot of ways
it's also one of the most important choices
we make.
So here's to sober driving, imagining others
complexly, and not paying attention to the
color of someone else's rented Lamborghini.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.